we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
i am hoping
that today
we are closing the books on the me
leaving the country saga
i was asked if you left the country
because things got bad where would you
go and so i gave an answer and then i
was told you're abandoning us you're not
a team player i'm canceling my
membership because i can't support
someone who would just leave if things
got bad and i had to say no no no guys
i'm not planning on leaving i'm not
planning on leaving i was asked if you
were to leave where would you go
um and then i was told oh but you sound
like a jew trader jews who take their
capital elsewhere
um okay let's hope that this voicemail
is the final note on this entire leaving
the country thing
to those people to all those people that
you say who contacted you via email to
let you know their dismay anger disgust
or threatening to or actually cancelling
their membership because they consider
you to be some kind of a trader some
kind of a jew trader uh they're banning
abandoning us or banning abandoning your
country blah blah blah
at least half of those people would do
the very same thing if they were able to
i think a lot of those people who
express negative thoughts towards you in
email
are the people who can't leave because
they're not able to leave they don't
have the wherewithal to lead
and
so there's that
uh i think you
addressed the question quite well
towards the end
uh you don't need to apologize
any any normal person
if faced with extreme circumstances
externally in his or her own country
would it such as human nature survival
desperate people do desperate things
it's not a question of being loyal or
patriotic look that
we're a nation of strangers
if any country was a country a nation of
strangers it's the united states because
the last thing we are
is united
so
don't let them trouble you
i hope you can make up any revenue you
might have lost from those mukes
who felt
because they can't do what you do
they have to be
they have to be uh
engage in retribution
in spite
of them
in the horse they wrote in on wow
you do what you have to do and by the
way that's not to say you can't continue
your show that you've uh that you can't
broadcast to people in in america from a
different country
technology just to do that yeah not only
that i've done it and there have been
there have been stretches of time where
i've been out of the us and the people i
just i didn't announce it because there
was no reason to announce it but nobody
had any idea uh so i don't think it's
not really a question of being able to
do the show so let's hope that that's
the final note on this leaving the
country thing i have no plan to leave
the country we will talk on today's
bonus show about the um resignation of
cnn's president over a consensual
relationship with an employee we will
talk about a push to make the lunar new
year a federal holiday and we will we
will actually talk about jury
deliberations in the roy moore
defamation case remember this is the
bonus show
much maligned by alex jones oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad right what an
endorsement and uh i invite you to sign
up at joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access and i will see
you on the bonus show momentarily